[MUSIC PLAYING]
KAYUN LAM: How's everyone doing?
Great?
Great.
Yeah, welcome.
Having fun so far?
Learning stuff?
Both at the same time?
Great.
Thank you very much.
My name is KaYun, together with
my colleagues Vince and Julie.
All three of us are customer
engineers for Google Cloud.
And we're going to present you
this session a "Modern Data
Pipeline in Action."
We're going to walk
through a few data pipeline
from collecting data, processing
the data, analyzing the data,
and discuss about the best
practices and considerations.
All right.
So let's just quickly
recap what data pipeline is
and what it is for.
As you can see,
different stages usually
exist in a modern data pipeline.
Usually it starts
with data injection,
you have to collect the
data, take the data in.
It could be coming from
servers, users, or IOT devices
these days.
Once we have
collected the data, we
have to transform it, cleanse
it, some kind of processing.
We then have to store the
data, [? put it ?] somewhere--
sometimes file systems,
storage device,
or maybe in a data warehouse.
And then once we have the
data in, we can take a look
and see what we can
derive from the data.
In the old days, it could be
a simple as an aggregation,
summation, group by
day, group by week,
or maybe these
days it can be very
common to do some
statistical modeling
or maybe use it for advanced use
cases like machine learning AI.
And then visualization.
It's a very, very
important step.
Usually it is used
for presenting
the results of the analysis--
pie chart, bar chart,
node-link diagrams, word cloud,
you name it.
Different types of
visualization techniques.
Usually these stages are
done in an orchestrated,
in an automated, fashion.
It could start with, for
example, a presence of the data
file, some events coming
in, some trigger, or maybe
the trigger is based
on a batch schedule.
Although there are cases that
maybe it is done manually
during development
phase, testing phase,
or maybe it is for ad
hoc analytics project.
We do hear a lot of
challenges from customers
who are trying to build
data pipeline these days.
And they are encountering
different types of things.
Starting with injection,
there could be a huge volume
of data coming in.
They're coming in
in different formats
at very, very high speed.
And then the transformation.
It can be tough to
just to cater for all
of those requirements
that are required
by the downstream application.
You have to add in all
those transformation rules.
You have to keep adding,
adding, adding until a point
that I'm not sure
whether you all
have the experience of talking
to your data integration team.
Hey, I just want to understand
how come the incoming data
file has a million rows and then
you're dropping 10% of them.
They got rejected, they
got put somewhere else.
What happened?
It's just getting
harder and harder
to understand what happened
in between the pipelines.
And of the storage
itself, I mean
with the huge volume
of the storage,
it is really getting tough
as an exercise on its own
just to architect
the storage system.
Just to make it highly
available, make it durable,
make sure that things are
backed up correctly, make sure
it can handle the
throughput that's coming in.
And then the size of
the storage will grow,
and you have to
figure out how to add
the storage in a way that
is not impacting the system
and then it can still catch
up with the requirements
of the [? IOT, ?] the
throughput, and things
like that.
And then when we get to
the analysis of the data,
well there are many cases that
so many different users having
their own careers to run,
you have to figure out a way
to tune it for
this user and then
tune it for a another
group of users.
And of course, with the data
volume, keep adding to it,
the queries may runs
slower and slower.
So it's not like a
one-off exercise.
You have to keep
monitoring it, you
know, all those things like
analyze it, run stats on it.
All those things just to
keep it up and running
and make it efficient.
Well, there are some other
cases that the data is not even
in one single place.
I mean they're in
different types of storage
in different data mounts.
They're just in different places
making it hard to analyze.
And finally onto visualization.
There are so many
cases that I've
seen in a customer situation.
They have a BI dashboard.
But then, the caveat
is that the data
available for
visualization, sorry,
it is just the latest
three months of the data.
If you're having good
luck in your company,
maybe OK, it's one year
of data, three years
of data in your dashboard.
It may not be all the data
set that you want to analyze.
People are doing this
usually to optimize
the performance of the
query so it's not overly
loading the dashboard.
To be honest in
many of the cases,
you don't get to run
the dashboard yourself.
It will be run essentially
by someone else,
you know, an
administrator, a server
generating the report for you.
8:00 AM in the morning, weekly
report, they send you a PDF.
The PDF has a chart.
You detach the PDF and
that becomes your reporting
repository.
So I know this session title
is called "A Modern Data
Pipeline in Action."
When we say action, let's
try to find some action that
is fun on a Thursday afternoon.
So let's play a game, shall we?
So I'm going to introduce my
colleague Vince on the stage
and he'll guide you through
a game as the action piece
in this session.
All right, Vince.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
VINCE GONZALEZ: Hi, everyone.
So what we did was
we built a demo.
We thought that
rather than pounding
through a whole bunch
of slides, instead
we'd get you involved in
actually building our data
pipeline in action.
So on the screen here
you'll see a bit.ly link.
If you'd like to
take out your phones
and hit this bit.ly
link in a browser,
you'll be taken
to an application
that we built for you
to actually generate
the data that we'll put
into a data pipeline,
and we'll visualize the results
here in the room in real time.
Your participation
here is not required.
But if you'd like to see
a data pipeline an action,
it would be really great if
you played along with us.
So please if you haven't
already, take your phone out.
Hit this bit.ly
link in your browser
and you'll be presented
with a simple quiz game.
In the quiz game,
it's really easy,
they're multiple
choice questions.
You hit the button
for the correct answer
and then answer
the next question.
We'll give you
guys a few seconds
to answer as many questions
as you can before we resume.
So while you're playing, we'll
switch to the demo laptop,
please.
And what you'll see
here is a dashboard.
As your answers flow in, we'll
see this dashboard update
in real time.
Nice to see those numbers moving
up as you all play the game.
Cool, so what you see here
is a real time dashboard
that we built with the help
of our friends at Looker.
We've got a couple of
sort of individual metrics
that we display on
the screen to show
the number of active users,
all the people of all time who
have taken our quiz.
And then we've got
a little time series
chart that shows
how many answers
are being put in per minute.
These things are updating on
slightly different refresh
schedules, so that's why you
may see the answers per minute
delaying a bit.
But these answers are actually
moving through our data
pipeline as we stand here.
Can we switch back to
the presentation, please?
Now what are we solving
with this data pipeline?
Usually what we hear
from our customers
is that there's a
handful of things
that they're solving for when
it comes to building out a data
pipeline.
One of the things
that's often the case
is that we want to get
timely access to the data.
Usually people
don't want to have
to wait for days or even
hours to get access to data
to start analyzing it
and looking for insights.
And so we don't want to have
to wait for long, drawn out
ETL processes to complete
before we can actually
start querying the data.
We may also have people
in our organization
who we want to enable to
make data driven decisions
but don't have very high
degree of technical skill.
They don't program in
Python or R or even SQL.
And so we need to enable
everyone in an organization
to make decisions
with data with tools
that are easy for them to use.
And finally, your data
engineers are out there
building the tools for these
other constituencies to use.
Your data engineers
actually also need
a way to process
data consistently,
and then when business rules
change or when bugs are found,
they may need to
actually go back
and reprocess the data that
had been already processed
by the streaming engine.
Let's look at how
we solve for this.
This is the architecture of
the game you just played.
You can see that we are
going from the user--
that's you-- through
our application.
We ingest data from the
app, deliver the events
down to some processing
layer which prepares
the data for analysis.
We store the data in
an analytics engine
where we can query
over the data,
build reports and dashboards.
And then finally, we've got
mechanisms within these tools
to actually share the data out.
So let's dive a
little bit deeper.
On the application,
what we did was
use Firebase to
implement the front end
that you were playing with.
We use Firebase Hosting for
all of the static assets,
the HTML, the
JavaScript, and so forth.
We used Firestore to store
the questions and your answers
to those questions.
And then we use Cloud Functions
to react to the submission
of the answers in the app.
And we also use
the Cloud Function
to react to the updates
of the Firestore database
in real time.
Those functions are
then emitting data
into a Cloud Pub/Sub topic.
Cloud Pub/Sub is
a serverless way
to deliver events from
an application, an IOT
sensor, what have you, store
it durably, and then deliver it
later for processing.
The other side of the
coin from a Pub/Sub topic
is a Pub/Sub subscription.
A subscription is used to
actually deliver events
down to interested consumers.
You can have up to 10,000
topics and subscriptions
in a GCP project.
We're only using a handful
of topics and subscriptions
in order to accommodate your
answers as they flow in.
Our consumer is a Cloud
Dataflow pipeline.
Dataflow is a fully managed
service for ingesting-- sorry,
not for ingesting but for
processing events and preparing
them for later analysis.
The data preparation may involve
just basic transformations.
Taking the data that's
ingested-- in our case,
we're ingesting JSON data.
Performing some
computation over it--
we might be computing,
say, a score over the data.
And then storing
that into some sync--
in our case, we're
using BigQuery.
Now, if I were delivering
this talk a year ago,
I'd probably have a screenshot
of a snippet of some Java code
that was reading from
Pub/Sub, optionally doing
some transformation
in the middle,
and then storing the
data into BigQuery.
Not everybody's
a Java developer,
but it's often the
case that we need
to be able to deploy these
kinds of pipelines simply.
So we've recently added
to the Cloud platform
a number of pre-built
data flow templates
that allow you to easily
ingest data from a source
and write it to a sync
optionally transforming it
as it passes through
a JavaScript UVF
that you can provide.
With these provided
templates, you
can get data from Cloud
Pub/Sub into things
like BigQuery or Cloud
Storage without writing
a single line of code.
In our case, what we're doing
is ingesting from Pub/Sub,
processing that data
minimally, and then writing it
into BigQuery.
We're also writing in an
archive out to Cloud Storage
as a bunch of Avro files.
We chose the Avro
format because it's
extremely well supported by all
of the other GCP components.
It's a first class citizen
with respect to BigQuery ingest
and all of the rest of
the suite of big data
tools on the platform.
You already saw the
dashboard that we showed you
a bit ago from Looker.
Looker is a great tool, it has
excellent support for BigQuery,
and is really very nice to
work with as I can attest.
But it's not the only option you
have for visualizing your data.
Google Data Studio
is built directly
into the Cloud platform.
It is free to use.
It's a great way to
really democratize
the ability of people
in your organization
to create visualizations
and share that out
to the rest of the organization.
And there's a long list of
other BI and visualization tools
that are supported
by our partners.
I talked about the
data engineer's need
to be able to reprocess
data and maybe
go back and recalculate things.
The Cloud Storage archive
is what enables this.
So having stored our events
in an archive on Cloud Storage
as a bunch of Avro files, should
a data engineer need to do so,
we can write another
pipeline that might go back
and reprocess all of that
data out of Cloud Storage
before writing it again
to our eventual sync.
This is usually run as something
like a batch job, in contrast
to the streaming pipeline
that you saw earlier.
What's great about this
framework, and Cloud Dataflow
in particular, is
that if I fix my bug
or change my business rules
in my streaming pipeline,
those transforms that I used
for the streaming pipeline can
usually be used pretty
much directly in a batch
pipeline that runs along side.
This is how we enable
the reprocessing of data,
the recalculation,
restatement of results.
When you run a batch pipeline,
it's not always the case
that the batch pipeline that
you're looking to execute
is the only thing
that needs to run.
You usually need some
way to orchestrate this.
There might be
dependencies that have
to be satisfied before
executing the batch pipeline.
Creating a database,
creating a table,
executing a different
Dataflow job,
or executing some bash script.
We recently announced
the general availability
of Cloud Composer which is
based on Apache Airflow.
Apache Airflow is a
service for orchestrating
complex data pipelines,
particularly of the batch style
that I'm describing here.
Cloud Composer is a
managed service for Airflow
and makes it really easy to
set up and manage and run
an Airflow cluster.
Now that I've taken you
through the architecture,
I'd love to welcome
KaYun back to the stage
to give you a little
bit of a deeper dive
into some of our
architecture choices.
[APPLAUSE]
KAYUN LAM: Thank you, Vince.
All right.
Thank you Vince for guiding
us through the modern data
pipeline in action.
So I would like to go back
and revisit it, and then
take a look at some of
the architecture decisions
that we have made when
presenting this solution.
Of course, just now
the example is a game.
In your use case, it may
or may not be a game.
It could be in a traditional
enterprise environment.
It could be some other kinds
of data processing needs.
We still want to
revisit or maybe go
through some of those
architectural decisions
to see if there's
something universal.
Maybe there's something that
you can borrow and apply
in your data pipeline
in your environment.
First of all, just
now the data flows
from Firebase, the
application that you
used your phone to play on.
And then eventually
it goes into BigQuery
for the dashboard
for the analytics.
Technically speaking, it is
actually doable, technically
feasible, to have the
data written from Firebase
into BigQuery directly.
As a matter of fact,
BigQuery actually
supports multiple ways
of ingesting data.
BigQuery can ingest
data in batch.
BigQuery, on the
other hand, also
has a streaming
insert mechanism.
That means when you
run a simple statement,
it actually can merge the
data, merge the results
between a streaming buffer
in BigQuery with the data
that it has been presented
in the table already.
So it is actually
very, very doable
to have Firebase to write the
data to BigQuery directly.
We choose not to do that.
We chose to put
something in between,
and that is what
we call decoupling.
In this case, we want the
application-- in this case,
in this example,
Firebase-- to focus only
on publishing the source
data, the source data
from the application
in its original format.
In this case, it is JSON data.
And just focuses on publishing
the data onto the Cloud Pub/Sub
topic.
The application doesn't
need to be aware of,
hey, what is the data
set name down the road.
Hey, where is BigQuery
or some other databases?
What is the data set name?
What is the table name?
How the schema looks like.
And then in many cases, it may
not be one single downstream
application.
Right now it could be one, it
could be a second one later.
And it can grow.
And then we don't
want to have so many
of those touch points
built into the source
application in this case.
Having Pub/Sub in this
case will make sure
that Firebase, the
source application,
only focuses on
publishing the data.
And it will let Pub/Sub be the
mechanism to fan out the data,
to have multiple subscribers
subscribing to the same topic.
Each Cloud Pub/Sub
topic supports up
to 10,000 subscribers.
You don't need to
handle to design
your own fan out mechanism,
Pub/Sub can do it for you.
The concept of message
[? bus, ?] service [? bus, ?]
this is not new, to be honest.
It has been around.
People have talked
about a message layer,
message queue, stream storage.
This is not new, to be honest.
But at the same
time, it has been
a little bit
challenging to architect
this kind of solution.
Issues that you may
have heard around,
message is stuck in a queue, the
processing cannot keep up with
the incoming data volume,
or if you are lucky to have
a solution that is
horizontally scalable,
it has multiple
partitions, multiple shots,
then you need to worry
about how should I shot it,
how should I partition it?
The source application may
need to calculate the shotting,
make sure that it is
evenly distributed.
If it is not evenly
distributed, how do you
split the shot to rebalance it?
It becomes the architecture
exercise on its own
to deliver this kind
of message solution.
In this case, in our
example, Cloud Pub/Sub
is a fully managed
service running
on Google Cloud Platform.
It is a global service.
That's one single end
point around the globe.
Meaning that when you are
publishing your messages
to the topic, you don't
need to worry about, hm,
am I publishing my messages
to US, to Europe, to Asia?
No, you're publishing
your messages to Pub/Sub
and Pub/Sub will
handle the rest.
You don't need to worry
about which partitioning
or which shot you're
publishing your messages to.
Cloud Pub/Sub will just
scale automatically for you
and you are just paying
for that data volume
that you're sending
to Cloud Pub/Sub.
The processing layer,
Cloud Dataflow,
it reads data from Pub/Sub.
There could be varying
volume of data coming in
throughout the day, throughout
the week, holiday season.
There are many of those
similar processing
framework can do something
like this horizontally scalable
manner.
But at the same time,
that horizontal factor
usually is a fixed factor.
Meaning that you design it
upfront whether it is four
[? nodes, ?] 10 [? nodes, ?]
10,000 [? nodes. ?] You have
to have a fixed set of computing
power in order to consume
the messages.
On the other hand,
Cloud Dataflow
can actually do something
like auto scaling.
Based on the
incoming data volume
coming from streaming or
maybe even from batch,
Cloud Dataflow has the ability
to scale up and scale down
the computing
resources underneath.
So that you can adjust it and
only pay for the resources
that you are truly consuming.
There's no need to over
provision your streaming
processing layer just to
cater for the high water mark.
And then in this
case, the destination
of the data BigQuery, it has
compute storage separation.
Meaning that when the
data volume grows,
you don't need to
necessarily tie
the storage cost with
the computing costs,
like the CPU and the memory.
You pay for the storage and
the processing separately.
This makes it simple,
elastic, and low cost.
When we are sending
data to the destination
under the consideration, under
the architecture decision is,
how do you want that
data to look like?
Traditionally speaking, I've
been in that kind of field,
like ETL jobs, trying to
fit into the data schema
on the data warehouse.
All those things are
simple as normalization
of the data, the star schema,
slowly changing dimension.
Just all those ETL jobs,
they are not really
doing something that is
business wise, but more to cater
for the target database format.
Usually the goal is
to fit into the schema
so that it is efficient
for that database queries,
or maybe it will
minimize the data storage
so that you're minimizing the
duplication, saving the storage
cost.
On the other hand, in
a modern data pipeline,
we can ease off on some of these
transformations in between.
The reason is that in a modern
data pipeline, especially
for example in this case,
what we have in BigQuery,
you don't have to force it to be
like a one-to-many relationship
table to split up the
data into multiple places.
In a modern data pipeline, a
storage system like BigQuery
when we're [? top ?]
storing the structure data,
you have the ability to
store it in a format that
is as close to the
source as possible.
In this case, there
could be arrays,
there could be
[? strokes, ?] there
could be complex data types in
the originating source system.
And you can persist the data
as close to the source format
as possible so
that you don't need
to worry about should I break
down the data into this table?
That table?
How does the [? EL ?]
diagram look like?
And things like that.
This allows the data
processing to be really fast.
We minimize the logic,
minimize anything
that may happen in
between, and now we
can have low latency
access to the data.
That is our goal.
And the example we
had just now, we
showed a streaming
example of us in the room,
playing with the phone,
and then sending that data
so that is streaming data.
In real life situation,
that streaming
may not be the only data source.
Usually you will be handling
a mixture of streaming data
sources and batch data sources.
They could be the
same data type.
They might be different.
So it is very, very important
architecture decision
to choose something that
you are not necessarily
writing two separate
data pipelines or two
separate pieces of codes.
Cloud Dataflow supports
both streaming and batch.
Meaning that when you're using
the underlying programming
model, you write the set
of transformation logic,
you write something,
some algorithm.
It's very, very easy to have
that same piece of logic
to work on streaming
data and also batch data.
So keep this in mind when you're
designing your data pipeline
to make sure that it is flexible
enough to handle both cases.
One use case, as Vince
mentioned earlier,
is on the reprocessing needs.
It could be based on changing
business requirements
or you have to go back
and fix something.
But very, very often, data is
a very, very valuable asset.
There are so many
cases that there
might be some insights
hidden in the raw data
that maybe in the future maybe
there's an upcoming analytics
project, someone in
your organization
just want to go back to
the data and take a look
and see if there's some
additional insights that you
can get out of the raw
data that could have
come in months or years ago.
So it is also very
important when
you are designing your data
pipeline to keep reprocessing
as one of the considerations.
You want to make it easy for
anyone in your organization
to just go back and say,
hey, I have an idea.
I want to take a
look at the old data
and see if there's a
certain kind of pattern,
and then I can come up
with this new prediction
algorithm which has to be
trained based on old data.
That's why reprocessing, having
this as architecture decision,
is important.
As supported in my previous
slide stream and batch,
reprocessing can take
advantage of stream and batch
capabilities in the Cloud
Dataflow's programming model.
And then you can go back and
process the existing data
and see what kind of additional
insights there you can get.
So here is kind of like a
flow chart on the high level
transformation that might exist
in a Cloud Dataflow pipeline.
In this example,
first of all, first
of the four boxes
over there, first box
reads from the Cloud Pub/Sub
topic and subscription.
Second passes the JSON message.
The third step is to turn it
into the BigQuery, the table
row format.
And then the fourth step
is to write to BigQuery.
You want to choose the
programming model that allows
you to express your pipeline.
And these are kind of
high level transformations
so you're not going to deal with
all those tiny, little details.
The Dataflow's
programming models
supports many other primitives
that are specialized
for streaming data processing.
Like a windowing
mechanism, for example,
a sliding window, fixed
window, session window.
So it is very
important when you're
designing your data pipeline
next time, keep this in mind.
Choose something that allows
you to express your pipeline
in these high-level primitives.
And when you are
designing something
to be expressed in
a high level manner,
it allows your data
pipelines to be portable.
Just now I've been talking
about Cloud Dataflow.
In fact, it supports
pipelines that
are written in Apache Beam SDK.
But Cloud Dataflow is
not the only option.
The Cloud Dataflow
does make it easier
to run your Apache
Beam data pipelines.
It proficients the
computing resources for you.
It scales up, scales down.
It rebalances the work like
what we have mentioned earlier.
But if you want to choose
to run it somewhere else,
you can do that.
Once you have written your
data pipeline in Apache Beam,
Cloud Dataflow is just one of
the several supported runners
behind the scene.
You can say, I want to run my
data pipeline on Apache Spark.
It could be on Apache
Apax, Flink, Gearpump,
Samza, or even locally when
you're doing development
on your workstation.
So when you're designing
your data pipeline,
you want to choose something
open so that on one hand,
you can run it on, for example,
Cloud Dataflow on a cloud.
On the other hand, if there
are some other requirements,
you can choose to run it on
your own premise environment
or some other environments.
There shouldn't be any lock in.
So with this said, I'll pass
the time to my colleague Julie
and then she'll explain to
you the customer stories--
the customers who are
running these modern data
pipelines on Google
Cloud Platform.
Thank you, Julie.
[APPLAUSE]
JULIE PRICE: Hello, everybody.
Thanks KaYun and thanks
Vince for walking us
through the concepts of
a modern data pipeline
and the architectural
decisions that go into creating
a modern data pipeline.
As KaYun mentioned, I
wanted to take a moment
to really make it real to talk
about how some companies are
creating modern data
pipelines of their own in GCP.
So all of the companies
that you see listed here
are doing some
really cool things
with big data analytics,
big data processing,
all with Google Cloud Services.
And some of them, most of them,
you've already heard about.
So the first customer I
wanted to talk about is Ocado.
Ocado is an online
grocery retailer.
They serve over 70% of
households within the UK.
They don't have a single
brick and mortar store
anywhere in the UK.
So they're competing with all
of these really large stores
that people go past
on their way home.
And so they really
need to find a way
to get their
customers to be loyal,
to make sure that they're
always purchasing through them.
So what they wanted to do was
create a big data analytics
platform which would help
them convince customers
of all of the benefits
of buying online
as opposed to in the stores.
And they also
wanted to make sure
that they were using data to
drive their business insights,
to do things like
inform the supply chain,
predict demand, and really
just overall improve
their logistics.
They had a problem because
their data was siloed.
They had business
data and product data.
Transactional data
was all sitting
in different places
across their data center,
and they had no means of
communicating with each other.
So what they knew
they needed to do
was come up with a way to
create a platform that could
pull all this data together.
And they did that in GCP.
So they were able to build
this advanced analytics
solution that could not only
process the data through,
but run advanced
analytics against it
to do things like determine
what would be best to improve
customer satisfaction, how they
could optimize their supply
chain, how they could really
get access to insights
about their business data
in closer to real time,
and ultimately reduce costs.
So all of those kind of
common business goals
that almost every company has.
So they did that by implementing
first and foremost BigQuery
as their data storage platform.
So BigQuery is where all of the
data ends up to be analyzed.
So they do click stream
analysis, customer analysis,
product and department analysis.
Everything you can think of
all happening in BigQuery.
And this is across over
two petabytes of data.
They also are using
Cloud Dataflow
for doing their transformations.
So you might remember Vince was
talking about Dataflow quite
a bit as well.
And then they're using Pub/Sub
for all of their data delivery.
So it's this kind of a common
pattern of Pub/Sub, Dataflow,
to BigQuery.
And now they took it even a step
further by integrating BigQuery
directly with TensorFlow and
Cloud Machine Learning Engine.
Ocado was one of the
very first customers
to even help us test the
Cloud Machine Learning Engine.
And what they did was create
these really awesome data
pipelines that do
very real things.
So one example of
that is the way
that when somebody
submits an order,
the items get picked and
packed and ready for delivery.
So let's say, I'm going to make
a curry for dinner tonight.
And I put into my
Ocado app that I
want some vegetables, a
protein, some lentils, rice,
and some nice naan bread.
It's around noon time, right?
I'm on my lunch, not
taking up my work time
with ordering my groceries.
And I go ahead and
enter that, and that's
when the system starts
to work really well.
Because now we have to
analyze where are these items?
In what warehouse?
What warehouse is closest to
where it needs to be delivered?
Are there perishables?
What can be picked now?
What has to be picked later?
And so it determines
the appropriate time
to do these things and sends
signals to the warehouses.
And the warehouses
have a number of robots
that are used to pick all of the
items in an automated fashion.
But they just don't
say, hey you, robot,
you are responsible
for Julie's order.
In fact, there's ML
swarm intelligence
that they've created
which will help the robots
work collaboratively
so that they
can go through the warehouse.
And many robots could be working
on picking my items, as well
as others, but making
sure that they all
end up in the right
package to be shipped.
And making sure that it's
all done in such a way
that everything ends up
on people's doors fresh as
could be with no perishables.
So it is really pretty
cool what they've done.
Even still, they're sending
all of the telemetry data
from the robots up to
the Cloud and they're
analyzing that so they can
do scheduling, to make sure
they have the right
number of robots
on the floor in each warehouse.
And to do things
like predictive wear
and tear, to make sure that if
they think that something might
happen to a robot, that
can pull it and replace it
with a well-working
robot before something
happens and interrupts
the workflow.
So that's what they've
done internally
using this modern data pipeline.
And they also determined that--
they do a really good job
with e-commerce.
And so they thought,
why don't we
create an e-commerce
platform that we
can sell to other customers?
So large brick and
mortars that also do
online, and they created
Ocado Smart Platform,
which leverages a lot of
these same types of pipelines
to ensure now that these other
retailers across the globe
can deliver the same type of
fantastic e-commerce experience
that Ocado does to
their customers.
Now, the next customer
that I wanted to talk about
is Brightcove.
So a very different company.
They're actually an
online video platform.
They serve content
for internet TV,
news media, various
different internet media.
So think all video streaming.
And Brightcove runs 8,500
years worth of video streaming,
video viewing each
and every month.
They have 7 billion
analytic events per day.
So that's a lot of data--
85,000 years worth
of video streaming
per month for all the
people that are watching.
And so they were
having a problem
because their legacy system was
kind of bursting at the seams.
They knew that they needed to
re-architect and re-platform.
And so they investigated a
number of different big data
stacks, and they
landed upon GCP.
And so what did they do?
They implemented
a data flow that
went from Pub/Sub for
event delivery, Dataflow
for all of their
transformations, and BigQuery
to land their data and be
able to perform analytics.
And they chose this because
all of those services
can scale to whatever scale that
they need without them having
to worry about whether or not
the infrastructure can handle
it.
So this story's a little bit
shorter than the last one,
but really interesting
nonetheless
just because of the grand scale
with the amount of information
that moves through the
pipeline every single day
and the amount of
information that gets
analyzed every single day.
And speaking of scale, that
brings us to our last customer
that I'd like to talk about.
So are there any
Spotify users in here?
A few.
So I personally use
Spotify every day.
I absolutely love the service.
So I was very excited to learn
that Spotify chose to put
all of their tech stack on GCP.
So we're not going to talk
about all of the tech stack,
we're just going to talk about
the cool stuff, of course,
the data stuff today.
Spotify had the largest Hadoop
environments in Europe--
a 2,500 node, 50,000 CPU
core Hadoop environment
with 100 petabytes of
capacity, 100 terabytes of RAM.
It makes me shudder
at the thought
of the expense of that system.
But it was really important
because over 20,000 jobs were
running on the system per day.
From 2,000 different
workflows, it
was supporting 100 different
teams within Spotify.
So you have to imagine
it was very complex.
It was very important.
They couldn't just break it down
and build it somewhere else.
So they knew that they wanted
to get out of the on-prem world
and out of the single
Hadoop cluster world.
And so they chose
to come to GCP.
And so maybe you might
recognize a pattern here.
What do you think they chose for
their ad hoc analytics and data
storage?
They chose BigQuery.
Their BigQuery
environment serves
over 10 million queries
and scheduled jobs
every single day--
I'm sorry, every single month--
processes 500 petabytes of data
every single month for all
of the different users that
need to query against it.
Also, you might guess,
that for event delivery,
they chose Pub/Sub.
And if you remember the scale
of what Brightcove was doing,
7 billion analytic
events per day,
Spotify has one
trillion requests
that go against Pub/Sub.
And Pub/Sub is able to
scale to handle that.
Not only just to
handle it, but 99%
of all requests that
come through Pub/Sub
have a maximum latency
of 400 milliseconds.
So I think they've got the
scale and the low latency
pretty much worked out for
that part of the pipeline.
Now data processing,
again you might have
guessed they're using Dataflow.
They run 5,000
Dataflow jobs per day.
But they also realize
that they had some things
that they wanted to
continue to do on Hadoop.
So there was some
workloads, some ETL
that they were doing in Hadoop
that they wanted to keep there.
And so they also
introduced another service,
which we haven't really
talked about today,
which is Cloud Dataproc.
And that's our managed Hadoop
environment within GCP.
Well, the big difference
between a traditional Hadoop
environment and Dataproc is that
we're able to take and decouple
the storage from the
compute so now you
can store your data in
Google Cloud Storage
and just re-point
your Hadoop jobs
to look at GCS instead of HDFS.
And in doing that,
that enabled them
to have very workflow specific
Hadoop environments that
only spin up when it's
time to run the job.
They spin back down
when it's finished,
and they only pay for
the compute resources
when they absolutely need them.
So you might have
seen, I'm not sure
if anybody sat in this
session yesterday,
but Spotify did a session
on their full migration
from app tier all the
way down to the back end.
So if interested, I
definitely recommend
taking a look at that if you
want to see all of the thoughts
and considerations they
went through when designing
their solution in GCP.
But the moral of the story, the
reason why I really bring it up
today, is because it was huge
for Spotify to no longer have
to worry about the
scale of infrastructure,
the stretching of
infrastructure,
whether or not they
had what they needed
for the amount of data
that was coming in,
or the growth that was
going to happen as they come
with new music licensing and
new users coming to the system.
Now they can just
analyze the data,
understand listener
behaviors, understand
how music tastes
correlate, and really build
a fantastic music streaming
and music recommendation
experience for the consumers.
So we're nearly there.
I know this is the very
last session of all of Next,
unless you're coming
to bootcamps tomorrow.
But before we separate,
there's a couple
of things we wanted to do.
First of all, does anybody
want to know who might have,
quote unquote, "won" the quiz?
Answered the most
questions right?
So you might see on the side
here in the upper right hand
corner of the app, which you
may have logged out of already.
If you log back in, you're going
to see what your username is.
We didn't want to put
anybody's email address
or name up on the screen.
So if we switch back over to the
dashboard, we can have a look
and see who answered the
most questions correct
and also who answered
the most accurately.
So let's see.
I can't see that far.
If we can see who the user is.
KAYUN LAM: FO8YX2.
JULIE PRICE: So it's
not a requirement,
but if you're still
sitting in here
and you know that
that's your user
and you want round of applause
from 300 of your new best
friends, go ahead and stand up.
Anyone?
[APPLAUSE]
It's a mystery.
And we also have somebody
who got 100% correct.
KAYUN LAM: Let me
do a quick refresh.
JULIE PRICE: 80% correct.
KAYUN LAM: HJZSY2.
JULIE PRICE: So if you're here
and you want the recognition,
please go ahead and stand up.
Again, not a requirement.
But thank you all
for playing the game
and for watching the "Modern
Data Pipeline in Action."
If we could switch back
to the slides, just a few
more things before we go.
First of all, you
have the opportunity
to make this real
for yourselves.
So everything that we
showed you here today,
everything that we built in
this modern data pipeline,
up until the point
of the visualization
you can build on your
own with this Codelab.
So you have this link here.
You'll have access to
the slides as well.
Additionally--
did I go too fast?
I'll wait until I
see all phones down.
Additionally, there
are also a number
of sessions that
are relevant to what
we talked about here today.
So there are sessions on
Firebase, on Dataflow,
on BigQuery, and Looker, and
how well they operate together.
And if you go ahead into the
next website or app and just
filter by data and
analytics, you'll
be able to see lots of
things about the things we
talked about today.
Finally, we have some
resources for you
to learn more to get
started with GCP.
If you don't already
have an account,
you can get a free trial account
so that you can build out this.
And that free trial account will
have more than enough credits
in it for you to
run that through.
And also, if you
could please, please,
please before you leave this
room open up the next app
and fill out the
survey to let us
know how we did so
that we can make sure
that we make next year's
Next even better than this.
We'd really, really
appreciate it.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]